hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday December 30th 2019 what's going
on how are ya oh my god it's the [ __ ]
last Monday of the decade I don't feel I
don't know I think maybe because there's
a million channels now there's a
thousand [ __ ] video games and all
this [ __ ] to watch it used to be a
bigger deal back in the day when like a
decade was ending they would do the
whole retrospective of what happened
this decade the biggest movie is the top
you know [ __ ] pop songs what went on
internationally we had so-and-so as
president and then this person went in
his you know came [ __ ] they did would
do all of that [ __ ] and what to look
forward to in the next next decade
flying refrigerator you know there was
something some stupid invention that was
allegedly gonna make your life easier it
doesn't it doesn't none of it makes it
easier it makes it more expensive
there's a short run it makes it easier
but in the long run it makes you have to
work more hours it makes you retire with
less and it makes you eat cat food
sitting above a [ __ ] overpass when
you [ __ ] 80 years old
you know maybe camped out of the house
you used to own and you're just looking
at the house going you know what I owned
that house for 40 years and I bought 37
flat-screen TVs I should only I should
have stuck with my square TV Oh bill
you've been alone all day haven't you no
believe it or not I've had a big family
day doesn't take much doesn't take much
for me to go to over the [ __ ] Falls
of Niagara mentally it doesn't take much
well why would you be so depressed I
don't know maybe because my team Jesus
Christ you know what I knew the Patriots
were in trouble when Paul virzi told me
that they were gonna win the Super Bowl
in in [ __ ] week three I know it he
came down like the [ __ ] mush in the
Bronx Tale
he actually said congratulations that's
how unbelievable but you know whatever
let's look at it in a positive way we
we're still in the playoffs we don't
have to deal with having a week off and
being all rusty I mean you know I don't
think we have a bunch of old guys
anymore we lost somebody [ __ ] guys to
free-agency it's a whole different team
this year
so we're still in there you know and we
only lost four games this year all right
three of which were to the Texans the
Chiefs and the Ravens who are all in the
playoffs
Pass Miami Dolphins is the only team I
believe that we lost to that we [ __ ]
that aren't gonna be in the playoffs oh
we get a chance to get revenge all right
and I know that Bill Belichick can come
up with the [ __ ] game plan to beat
any one of those teams and I know that
Tom Brady can execute it and I know that
Edelman can catch those [ __ ] balls
here's the thing if the other [ __ ] we
need the other people to step up not
everybody but I'm just saying this
there's some new components into the
[ __ ] who's a more what's their it
just need to [ __ ] elevate your
goddamn game or it's not good it's not
gonna be good it's that's not gonna be
good I am still you know I'm right now
I'm actually recording this Sunday
afternoon it's almost halftime and my
pick to win the Super Bowl the Seattle
Seahawks
are looking like they didn't even know
this game was going to happen today
you know the 49ers whose defense has
looked like absolute [ __ ]
for the last [ __ ] month letting up 30
points here 40 [ __ ] points there I
don't know what's going on now they're
looking like lights out but I don't know
it's still alright I'm still to [ __ ]
win the thing I don't know why either
that or it's gonna be them in the Raven
sets that's what I think I just don't
think Casey has the [ __ ] defense
I think Jackson's gonna [ __ ]
I'm up a goddamn wall they're not their
defense isn't gonna be good enough I
just don't think that they're gonna come
up with a game plan to stop that [ __ ]
guy in that team and their defense the
Ravens have a good defense I don't know
[ __ ]
I got a kid this is as much as I've been
able to pay attention all right I think
all the fat people in Houston are
probably very excited that their team
has an eighteenth game of the year
giving them an excuse to go out and turn
on the smoker once again
and slather it with some barbecue sauce
you know and try to squeeze in one more
heart attack before the end of the
decade I'm sure that's going on in
Houston okay
I'm sure the people of Baltimore are
very excited they are they are they are
writing signs
most of them misspelled you know because
of the lack of I don't know whatever I
learned on the wire but they weren't
taking care of their youth you know who
else kind of [ __ ] on here get around
about ignor way oh then you got Kansas
City Kansas City you know what are you
gonna do I mean I don't know I don't
know they're just one of those
franchises like they have the offense to
do it I don't think they have the
defense all right
and there's my picket and then the
Buffalo Bills I mean I don't I don't
know why they were in it you know it's
like you know I can't believe that there
is a professional sports franchise in
that town of like 1,800 people it's
ridiculous it's like what is this the
1940s can the Buffalo Bills please move
to me even Rochester has more people
that I think Buffalo
nobody wants like a buffalo I'm kidding
good luck to all you guys
and then you got the Green Bay Packers
you get Aaron who knows it's kind of up
for grabs this year we shall see and the
Saints you know hey Jameson Winston they
said the first quarterback ever to throw
for 30 touchdowns in three and 30
interceptions 30 touchdowns 30
interceptions in a year I gotta be
honest with you I think that's actually
a [ __ ] cool stat
the man is not afraid to swing it you
know let me [ __ ] interception stood
Brett Farve and I can't believe it you
know what did he do forty and forty one
year gives a [ __ ] you know he's playing
for Tampa Bay he's got to do what he's
got to do he's he's he's he's a victim
of the the system over there I love when
that happens it was just like [ __ ]
right before the half ends Seattle
tackles they're running back in the
49ers he's clearly on the ground it's
not a fumble but he's still gotta pick
the [ __ ] thing up and [ __ ] running
all the way down to the end zone even
though they blew the whistle of Coach
it's that's one of the few things that
NFL football players actually follow
through one oh by the way they showed
this all at Seattle's calling a timeout
sneaky paint takes it to fumble he's
chewing his gum Pete Carroll looks like
a state senator he's the most non
coaching looking guy I've ever seen in
my life
he's already on the ground it's not a
[ __ ] fumble let's go now where
exactly was his the back of his jersey
does it touch the grass that isn't grass
before the ball starts to move we have
to go to New York and find out you guys
watch the [ __ ] college playoffs
I don't do [ __ ] this weekend all I did
was [ __ ] watch sports and hang out
with my kid I had a great time I did
some spots too I was having the best
time I'm since I've been on the other
side of that [ __ ] test
I've just been chilling you know not
reading not bettering myself as a human
being fight you off is [ __ ] cold hey
come on in the lovely Nia everybody ever
since we had a kid Nia your your your
[Music]
guest spots on this podcast have dropped
off drastically
hey somebody sent can I read this thing
about that about the [ __ ] impossible
burger I know right cuz we were like oh
no this is greatest thing ever night my
thing was how do they make it so [ __ ]
red I know yeah it does look like it's
bleeding and it's not meats so why does
it look like that yes so let's find this
out if I typed in my password right yes
I did yeah I think that's but I mean I
make like lentil burgers in like the way
you make it red is you yeah yeah beets
in there but I mean that's also a part
of the recipe right just the beets I
don't think it's meant to be like make
it look like real me like impossible is
even though impossible impossible no
wouldn't wouldn't I the person said if
you want to have it look like me a
little bit you can put beets in it oh
okay all right so here we go don't eat
the impossible burger all right did you
really have to ruin it person who's
writing in to give us facts I know I
know but they got to do it here we go
it says guten morgen Billy vitals hey
unless you want you want lactating [ __ ]
tits don't eat that's offensive to me
why because I at one point had lactating
[ __ ] tits and there's nothing wrong and
they fed you whoever this is guten
morgen with some some German [ __ ] yeah
but yeah as a guy you know would you
want me to lactate Mia I wouldn't you're
not gonna lags I don't care went where
this letter is going okay Tony that
impossible whopper oh that's the
impossible whopper
I'm talking about I get that [ __ ] at the
store anyway that soy burger has 44
milligrams of estrogen according to a
study it seems like an extraordinary
claim but this study was performed by a
reputable lab and got consistently
respectable results repeatable sorry my
eyes are going not only is that 44
milligrams of estrogen asterisk 18
million times higher than a normal
whopper which contains 2.5 it also
it is also full of little huh below
below and this [ __ ] that makes it red
well I'm not eating the [ __ ]
impossible whopper they're just talking
about the meat though listen no no
they're talking about the realist is
produced by splicing bacterial genes
into a strain of yeast making it a GMO
product yeah that's not organic any
man's the makers of the impossible
burger claim it has 25 grams of protein
which isn't technically a lie what they
do fail to mention however is that it
lacks any of the nine essential amino
acids meaning you barely get any of the
nutrition a complete protein has the
doctor who ran the study notes four of
these a day is enough to grow tits on a
man and cause lactation to booze you're
not gonna have lactation unless you're
growing a child inside of you that
doesn't make any [ __ ] sense why would
you lactate and you don't even have a
bit that's what it's for your body knows
that you're growing a baby and so it's
providing milk for the baby you're not
gonna be lactating because you ate the
impossible burger can I ask you a
question are you a doctor no but I'm a
woman who's had a child and I have
common [ __ ] sense why do people
lactate bill why so you're like you like
that thing
are you that mother that tells it like
it is I am well why do animals lactate
why to feed their babies you're not
gonna be lactating you might grow
boobies all right I'm just playing
devil's advocate do animals eat the
impossible whopper no what if they ate
four in one day no one's gonna eat four
in one day like what if it's a hungry
male wolf and eats for today is he gonna
go up in the [ __ ] that milk coming
out of its non-existent tits you know
that the impossible burger is junk food
okay but this idea that you're gonna
start lactating as a man doesn't make
any [ __ ] sense
you're not growing a child you're not
gonna like well I'll tell you who's
gonna find out not America because we'll
[ __ ] down for of anything that you
got in one [ __ ] day so break it down
a regular whopper has two point five
nanograms of estrogen the impossible
whopper has 44 milligrams of estrogen
female birth control has point 0.05
grams of estrogen aside from the obvious
feminizing effects that much estrogen
has on a male and also it's also
carcinogenic soy and other estrogens are
linked to testicular and prostate cancer
in men and breast cancer and women
there's a link always on the podcast and
don't give up on the polar bears okay if
I'm not saying like the yes them you
don't know what you're talking about
please keep talking the impossible meat
is is junk food but sure know just start
lactating that's ridiculous that's a
ridiculous claim ridiculous guys your
question was that he's what he's
suggesting is like I didn't think I had
the plumbing for that you don't like I
thought like my you know like you know
in a kitchen where there's a false
drawer like I thought that's what male
nipples were like like like there's no
milk behind that counter it's never
gonna happen it's never gonna happen how
do you wag you don't have any white lab
coats what do you know this [ __ ] guy
does well he keeps you out he throws
weird [ __ ] sexist language now I'm
not into it can you [ __ ] ladies get
over yourselves you know it's about you
and not testicular cancer I am offended
I'm so glad you didn't say this in
November when I had a mustache I don't
want you to get testicular cancer too
much estrogen is bad for everybody
including women so but you're not gonna
start lactating
that's absurd I don't understand how you
turn this into a male-female argument
this guy is arguing for humanity [ __ ]
thing I've ever heard and it's just like
a dumb [ __ ] stupid male to the dude
you gotta [ __ ] have so much estrogen
you're gonna grow [ __ ] tits and [ __ ]
start lactating dude like you don't want
that the feminization with the
impossible burger like you shut the [ __ ]
up okay
he didn't say that yeah he did no you
leading basically basic
avoids being silly but like this idea
that you're gonna lactate eating that
like stop it already
but yes you are correct the impossible
burger as junk food everybody knows that
all right good
doctor James Stangl what you mean you
leave and after you just [ __ ] get
back to it good get back to the kitchen
we belong what do we dis thing I don't
know I was gonna do part of it now and
just [ __ ] it up trying to knock it out
cuz I know tomorrow morning I gotta
watch the kid Oh what are you making you
bugged you head and fell down you did
rub some dirt on it you're good I love
when she says I'm okay I'm fine
hey we're not have an impossible meet
are we alright
I bought some real beef there you know I
think this is a Showtime series a guy
eats too many burgers he starts
lactating
alveta they an [ __ ] unbelievable see
what happens sir when you try to make a
point to a woman and you end in the
first sentence you say [ __ ] tits she
couldn't hear your message alright it's
for the rest of you still listening
alright
Stangl impossible burgers are made of
what alright the impossible whopper now
there's now to be fair to all the other
impossible things out there hey did they
call it impossible so you can't sue him
so when this [ __ ] milk coming out of
your titties they're like well we said
it was impossible the [ __ ] do you want
from us what were we supposed to call it
the [ __ ] lactating [ __ ] tit burger
all right the impossible whopper is
being advertised by Burger King as a
plant-based alternative to the whopper
when food manufacturers started talking
about making artificial meat I too
thought it would be impossible to make a
hamburger cheaply enough to make it
competitive
you see I assume that they would have to
buy the individual amino acids the
building blocks for protein and
chemically string them together in the
proper order
then remove the Regents reagents rege
and gents I don't know what that is
chemicals needed to cause the chain
reaction and then add something to give
it the right texture the reality is
people just eat the right natural foods
all right my I'm talking to myself too
you know just go get some [ __ ] green
veggies that you know maybe weren't
cross pollinated with something else
which is very hard to do you know why do
why do politicians make so such little
money why is that it's so [ __ ] [ __ ]
who make [ __ ] like this can get it on
the market for free and all those
[ __ ] [ __ ] you saw the Obamas they
bought like some zillion dollar house
you know the Clintons are always buying
[ __ ] the bushes are buying up half a
[ __ ] South America you know they they
were public servants where's all that
money call they give speeches to all
right the impossible whopper made by
impossible foods bypassed all of those
steps the ones that I was just
mentioning it let's compare the two the
impossible whopper patty is made from 24
ingredients the most important
ingredients so protein the whopper patty
has just one ingredient that would be
beef that's pretty respectable for
Burger King I mean back in the day I
mean do you didn't know what the [ __ ]
was remember McDonald's came out there
with it's like you know we got our new
burger now with 100% real beef an
obvious question was what the [ __ ] was
it before the impossible whopper has 630
calories most from the added oils the
whopper has 660 calories so about 5%
less
calories this is not a huge improvement
Jesus Christ the [ __ ] whopper is
taking a [ __ ] beating in this the
impossible whopper I should say the
impossible whopper has 25 grams of
protein the whopper has 28 grams seems
pretty equal only 11% less protein in
the impossible whopper however not all
proteins are created equal there are 20
amino acids 9 of which are essential
meaning your body cannot make them so
they are required in the diet each of
those essential amino acids must meet a
certain level you want to read the rest
of this everybody I'm kind of interested
well I wasn't I know in tension
all right this person writes back wrong
please read this blog from impossible
foods about why the impossible burger
uses soy well why would you listen to
the person on [ __ ] trial
I want to rather listen to a doctor I
mean possible foods they got a dog in
this fight that [ __ ] doctor unless
they were hired by the people that make
the Big Mac you know this is gonna be
I'm calling this right now this is gonna
be an oscar-winning movie someday right
when half the male population has
[ __ ] milk coming out of their titties
and Burger King finally admits all right
we knew right now they'd pin it on one
[ __ ] pimpled kid on the frialator he'd
take the fall he'd be the Ollie north of
the [ __ ] Burger King it's all the
same it's all the same [ __ ] game okay
and the game is press record and talk
for an hour that's what the game is on
this podcast I don't know what game you
guys showed up to watch but that right
there is what the [ __ ] is going on all
right
well guess what guess we went to the
farmers market today and got some beets
and all of that [ __ ] now before any of
you [ __ ] [ __ ] okay wake up on the
wrong side of the haystack and then got
to start [ __ ] sending me emails
telling me that a lot of the [ __ ]
food at the farmers market is also not
healthy because these corporate run
farms have figured out a way how to
sneak their food in there I real
I said alright I'm doing the best I
can't you know what's hilarious we went
to this farmers market right and my
lovely wife Nia who I gotta tell you
right now you know you go through ups
and downs in your marriage I I don't
think I've ever loved him more we just
had the best holidays she's [ __ ]
awesome
having said that see that I established
credibility I said a bunch of wonderful
things about my wife so now I'm gonna
trash her alright I'm not saying she's
dumped she's just not smart
don't kidding so we're gonna go to the
farmers market and you know you know how
people are it's [ __ ] monkey see monkey
do so we're going down there and she and
I go alright let's bring the stroller my
daughter's too big for a stroller at
this point but like the stroller we can
use it underneath part to put all the
you know the vegetables and [ __ ] that we
get that are allegedly organic and you
know where the celery was allowed to
walk around before they picked it
whatever the [ __ ] they talked about down
there with their [ __ ] bargain stocks
so I go when we just bring you know
bring the big stroller right and she's
just like you know she goes okay just
like why don't we get one of those like
wagon things why we lose wagon things
that we always see everybody down there
they put their kids in them and they
collapse them all their photobomb like
cuz we don't need it we don't need it we
have a [ __ ] stroller you know see
I'll make it a good point but then I say
[ __ ] and I ruin it
I go we got a [ __ ] stroller we can
just stick the thing underneath and
she's like no just seems like easy I'm
like we haven't been at the farmers
market since before I went to New York
to do that movie that was like in May
that's not true is it yes it's true we
don't need it we don't need it because
then it's just gonna be this [ __ ]
thing that's just sitting in the garage
I don't know if you guys know anything
about me but I am NOT into Clark alright
I'm not into clutter
I'm not into women with ideas there's a
lot of things I'm like [ __ ] it with you
this is what I notice when I go over
people's houses alright
[ __ ] clutter the problem areas
alright the laundry room okay you have
dirty and clean clothes just down there
you don't know what's going on right
who's in the holding cell who's down
here to bail them out you don't know
who's a good guy who's a bad guy what it
is just a [ __ ] [ __ ] show you do your
laundry
you [ __ ] fold it and you put it away
you finish the job you freak await you
go to Baghdad you take them out you
finish the job kidding there's that then
there's like behind doors that's another
place people like to my wife likes to
just stick [ __ ] behind doors and I take
it out and I just put it on her side of
the room she goes what are you doing I
go you know what am i doing what are you
doing why is that there won't you put in
the closet cuz there's no more room well
then guess what you got too much [ __ ]
stop buying [ __ ] what do we need we got
clothes we got a [ __ ] house that we
need to pay off for [ __ ] sakes all we
need is food go out and buy food stop
buying all this other [ __ ] [ __ ] then
garage is the last area I [ __ ] hate a
garage that you can't put a car at
that's what the [ __ ] it's for it's not
to [ __ ] house all of the [ __ ] that
you didn't need in the first place but
now you have an emotional connection too
and you can't let go of it so then you
just [ __ ] stick it out there
it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] show so that's what
now that's what I do
I just [ __ ] you know my wife Wow my
god I love this chair we should get
another one for another for the other
room no no we have it you want to
[ __ ] be on this chick
sit in the chair in this room it's a
[ __ ] chair it's touch speakers what
do you need two for sorry whatever we
all have our [ __ ] role in a
relationship and that's my role my role
is to
make sure you let me tell you something
right now guys especially stay on your
[ __ ] woman about buying [ __ ] because
you know what they'll do they'll [ __ ]
buy so much [ __ ] [ __ ] they'll start
going we need more space we need a
bigger [ __ ] house then you got to buy
a bigger house you have not increased
the amount of people in the [ __ ]
house
you just bought too much [ __ ] and then
you don't anymore closet space [ __ ]
get rid of it you want the [ __ ] I gotta
get a [ __ ] zillion of those goddamn
you know those bags cuz you're not
supposed to have plastic bags of brown
bags anymore you know I we gotta we have
like [ __ ] 40 million of them you know
so you know what I'm gonna [ __ ] do
I'm gonna just [ __ ] throw ten in her
car five in mind and then I'm taking all
the rest of them and I'm going down to
[ __ ] Skid Row where all those
homeless people got all the plastic bags
and [ __ ] they always need bags they need
a they bags I'm gonna [ __ ] give it to
them that's it free up that [ __ ]
cupboard that's my [ __ ] all right I am
not living in that [ __ ] house with
that chair with all this [ __ ] on top of
it you can't [ __ ] sit down you can't
put your car in the [ __ ] garage I'm
also not gonna keep buying [ __ ] and then
dumping it off down at the [ __ ]
goodwill either I'm not doing that [ __ ]
either I'm just gonna [ __ ] I'm done
with [ __ ] I don't need any more [ __ ]
okay until they have holes in my [ __ ]
socks like you should see the [ __ ]
socks and underwear I'm finally
replacing I've had these things since
before like Obama was elected I know I
am with the Sox I have socks that I had
when I was still in my 30s I'm gonna be
51 next year you know they don't know
they just if they're fine they're faded
but they don't have holes in them I
can't kill him so anyway whatever that's
just my [ __ ] philosophy but anyway I
I told you I'm recording this here on
Sunday and I am celebrating 400 days of
no booze unless you count the shots
unlike well I did
the other night when I had a [ __ ]
cold but I'm he can't taste the booze
it's not a funny time a party how do you
know I had the sniffles
so the Seattle gonna [ __ ] show up and
[ __ ] play it make me look like I know
something about football are they just
gonna [ __ ] sit here I'll tell you
what it annoyed me when they was talking
about the noise in that Stadium and they
never bring up the that [ __ ] cheatin
ass [ __ ] that they've been in [ __ ]
stadium to make those people sound
louder than they are the [ __ ]
Patriots ever did that if they ever
[ __ ] did that or the game today when
I was watching the field goal kicker
just dragging the football and on the
turf extremely aggressive
if the Pats do that what is this about
what is woody what is he doing you the
ball did he doctor the ball somehow so
we could go a little further or stay
away from their best returner
all right Seattle gets a three it out
nice nice there's a nice return
all right there you go anyway I think
the Bruins went 3-2 to they went 3-2 to
with like three minutes left home at
home with the sabers they're back to
their winning ways that's always nice
but anyway 400 days without booze so the
next big milestone for me will be 500
days in like April which at this point I
can do no problem but I'm really just
trying to get to my 51st birthday 52nd
I'll be 52 next year what am I talking
about and I can say for the rest of my
life at 51 I didn't have one drop of
[ __ ] booze no I don't know I don't
know if I'm gonna go back I miss it I
ain't gonna lie to you miss the way it
makes me fail no I'm gonna wait till my
kids grown up you know but she turns 21
or something like that man and hey you
know if I can freak her out just
immediately start slamming shots where
was this guy my entire childhood he was
he was on the bench so you wouldn't be a
[ __ ] you know you gotta be a [ __ ]
active member of society you're not
gonna have that with a [ __ ] face dead
shit-faced alright well we've been
talking about impossible burgers let's
talk about delicious [ __ ] meat well
they don't have to split atoms and all
of this [ __ ] crap
put your box everybody all right talk
about what you're most looking forward
to in 2020 oh I'll tell you New Year's
Day when I bring my bundle of butcher
box meats to the golf course
right outside the Rose Bowl to go to the
granddaddy of them all celebrating my
third decade of spending New Year's Day
it all started way back in 2009 with the
USC Trojans against the the the Penn
State Nittany Lions you know [ __ ] what
was that guy's name they're the
pedophile he was on the field that day
for the [ __ ] Penn State guys Sandusky
Joe paw Wright was coaching the team
Sneaky Pete Carroll about ready to run
out the door and they had the but fumble
guy he's quarterback that's where it all
started you know now we're back Oregon
against Wisconsin I've already seen this
matchup about ten years ago I want to
say what's his face Marcus Mariota
someone of those [ __ ] guys was
quarterback or something
anyway that's what I'm looking forward
to what are some new year's resolutions
you're making to find out if the
information about the impossible burger
that I just received is correct this
year I'm going to eat better and spend
less time and money at the grocery store
thanks to put your box are they writing
this for me to say this listen this year
I'm gonna I'm not gonna buy anything
other than food I don't [ __ ] need
anything I don't [ __ ] want anything I
want a clutter-free house I want to
[ __ ] rather than buying [ __ ] I want
to take that money and put it towards my
[ __ ] mortgage pay the thing off
alright
and then just sit on the back porch and
stare at the tree line smoking a cigar
oh that sounds good you know slowly ease
my way back into abuse
alcohol maybe this is why they write
copy for me sorry this year I'm gonna
eat better and spend less time and money
at the grocery store thanks to a bunch
of bucks I actually [ __ ] want to eat
better each month they sent a box of the
highest quality meat for a better price
than the grocery store which gives you
more time to spend cooking and sharing
delicious meals with family and friends
each box has nine to eleven pounds of
meat enough for 24 individual meals or a
snack in Houston Texas packed fresh and
it slipped frozen you got to respect
Houston they don't give a [ __ ] they they
were the fattest city two years in a row
I mean that's a [ __ ] dynasty in the
fat world you know we all know that too
fat now to shape anybody to get up for
that third year you know [ __ ] a drink at
a Sunday out of the Stanley Cup at that
point sorry packed fresh and ship frozen
to vacuum-sealed so it stays that way I
can customize my box I'll go with one of
theirs either way you're gonna get
exactly what you want options like 100%
grass-fed and finish be free-range
organic chicken heritage breed pork
wild-caught alaskan salmon and sugar /
nitrate free bacon it's the way mate
meat should be you know something with
all this controversy with the impossible
meat I before I can figure that I I get
any money I gotta get from this you know
there's a [ __ ] cow we didn't slap it
around at a grass it's [ __ ] delicious
with butcher box you get the highest
quality meat for just around six dollars
a meal and they even have free shipping
nationwide except Alaska in Hawaii the
appendices pendous itis --is of the
United States right now you get two
pounds of salmon absolutely free imagine
if you got killed as a salmon er then
they don't even charge for if you must
be like what the [ __ ] you know if fish
couldn't like meet all those little
flippers they have on the side if they
could lift them up you know if they had
shoulders to shrug that's what they'll
be doing plus $20 off your first box
just go to butcher bucks com / / or use
the promo code burr at checkout that's
butcher box com / / or use the promo
code burr at checkout
alright simply safe everybody on average
or Burghley happens
every 23 seconds in the United States
how is that [ __ ] possible
approximately two million burglaries are
reported a year in the US you know so it
was funny is it takes every 23 seconds
as a burglary so I'll say those three if
we're gonna happen the amount of time it
takes me read this copy not because
burglaries are increasing it's because
of my lack of ability go Marshawn Lynch
Marshawn Lynch is he gonna come back is
he gonna make it happen oh look at this
the Seattle Seahawks are driving Russell
Wilson such a great quarterback so
underrated he's up there in Seattle
nobody cares there's a flag on the
[ __ ] play well it's the NFL so you
know it's gonna be against the defense
don't you dare call holding they're not
gonna call a push-off holding offense oh
you [ __ ] zebra [ __ ] you Pete Carroll
there's no flavor left in that gum he
just keeps chewing it gotta love him
let's see did he hold them oh yeah oh
yeah
Jesus Christ he's [ __ ] Auburn in his
neck sorry what's crazy is that only one
in five homes have home security
probably because most companies don't
make it easy
complicated installation and salespeople
long term contracts fully hidden fees
astronomical monthly fees that's why
simply safe should be your choice for
home security it's comprehensive
professional home security at a fair
price and right now and right now is
your last chance to access their holiday
savings the Monday morning podcast
listeners get a free security camera
plus a twenty plus twenty five percent
off your security system two stat the
new year simply safe offers 24/7
professional monitoring a smart lock and
video doorbell defend your front door an
arsenal of sensors and cameras cover
every inch of your home simply safe
gives real time video confirmation to
police in the event of a break-in so
police respond up to 3.5 times faster
there's no contract hidden fees or fine
print prices started
fifteen bucks a month simply safe really
does deals this big so now's your chance
get 25% off your system plus a free HD
security system so that you can take
advantage of their video video
verification technology it's simply safe
calm / / and hurry
this sales ends the sale ends January
7th simply safe calm / / lovely Neil's
back what's up what do we have it what
are we having I am Oni what are we
having any impossible greens
I love it
roasted rutabaga alright let me I'll hit
pause on this and I would have a nice
dinner here and then I'll be back in a
half a second because of you know the
technologist again look at Seattle I
picked them to win the Superbowl Nia are
you a pre impressed no okay alright and
I'm back and you know what the 49ers
what are they doing here they go for
[ __ ] two points with three [ __ ]
minutes left to do what what the [ __ ]
kind of world is this now why would you
do that you basically say well we know
they're gonna score another couple of
touchdowns why would you do that [ __ ]
stupid jesus [ __ ] christ
I don't even I don't even understand
sports anymore what the [ __ ] was wrong
with being up 22:7 cuz you know going to
what touchdowns you'd be 21 [ __ ] 20
in what world you living in the
hypotheticals at this point what the
[ __ ] maybe what maybe they just get a
field goal a field goal makes it [ __ ]
and we would have been 20 to 10 then
they score another touchdown
alright then it's what it's [ __ ]
22:17 I don't know then when they touch
down their head field I don't
[ __ ] get it you just leave in points
I get it in the end of the game I
understand - was he in the game was
[ __ ] famous living so I fight you
take your [ __ ] points all these
[ __ ] times they go for it on fourth
down that's the [ __ ] you used to get
fired for i watch NBA hoop you guys some
guys seven foot five taking a
three-pointer with nobody underneath any
they don't put them on the bench it's
laughs you know nice attempt you at the
rim they're [ __ ] transylvanian
east-european [ __ ]
frankenstein-looking white dude what
happened to the American white male in
the NBA lately just we just suck we
can't [ __ ] get in anymore
it's all it's it's the [ __ ] oh it's
all [ __ ] the behind the Iron Curtain
white guys it's really weird how like
[ __ ] goes through like cycles you know
what I mean I think as you go to Eastern
Europe and those people don't even have
cell phones see the left you know what I
mean so they're just out there they're
just whooping it up all day and you know
our kids are eating you know [ __ ] that's
gonna make a black tape we're a bunch of
fat [ __ ] and I don't I don't think
we're not bringing it
we're not bring it was it Michelle Obama
gonna fix that wasn't she she was the
one who was about the kids
I need a cause to wrap to define my
identity I'm sorry I know I make fun all
these [ __ ] people and Who am I Who am
I I'm just a guy that ain't an
impossible [ __ ] burger who might be
[ __ ] able to nurse a child at some
point I don't know is this the [ __ ]
world we live in is this the kind of
technology you were looking for um all
right what else well we didn't talk why
didn't I I started I began I brought it
up was the round one of the NCAA college
football playoff your LSU Tigers webapp
I didn't know they gave up the Heisman
Trophy I've been so [ __ ] busy jobber
Oh congratulations and I think the
matchup everyone was talking about was
LSU against Ohio State and then you know
this guy who couldn't even make the
[ __ ] team
could possibly go and win a championship
but another you know against the team
that wouldn't start him or give him any
play in time I thought that was
interesting oh now they're gonna review
the [ __ ] two-point conversion [ __ ]
ridiculous I don't understand how they
got that view either when they don't
have a [ __ ] dog they don't have a
[ __ ] roof on that Stadium somehow
they're directly above it you know Ben
you're telling me there's no Big Brother
sorry
anyway the LSU game was a it was a game
for like [ __ ] I don't know six
minutes and then they just Jesus Christ
Joe burrows seven touchdown passes in
the first half over 400 yards in the
first half jefferson their receiver had
like 180 plus yards in the first half
okay I'll tell you right now that
[ __ ] chuck wagon that came out I
think it had a bunch of impossible
burgers on it and the Oklahoma Sooners
ate it cuz that was not a good game on
the other hand the Clemson Tigers
against the Ohio State University was an
amazing game unfortunately there was a
couple of [ __ ] calls but I don't feel
bad for Ohio State just cuz they've been
on the other side of [ __ ] calls that
went their way so you know somebody on
Twitter said Ohio State fans wake up
complaining about the officiating
everybody's fanbase pitches about him
but like I gotta be honest with you I I
thought you know all right that was
helmet-to-helmet but that didn't seem
like it should have been the injection
kind and also that looked like a catch
to me but I don't know when I catches it
was because it was away from his body
and then he has to pull it in I mean he
caught it and he took like two and a
half three steps at what point is he in
possession of the ball the ball is not
moving it's in his hands both of his
hands are on either side of the ball
she's the left number on the front side
of his jersey I don't know I'll state
you got [ __ ] on that one but you know
what you had a [ __ ] coming to you
it's how it works just like the Oakland
Raiders think the Patriots got [ __ ] in
the late 70s and then the Raiders had
that [ __ ] coming to him and it was
the Tuck rule that's what happens what
goes around comes around so quit you cry
in there Columbus alright so there you
go you got Clemson verse LSU who do you
like I don't know I gotta tell you I was
really impressed with Clemson's
adjustments because in the beginning it
just looked like Ohio State was clearly
the better team and was just gonna
dominate them and all of a sudden they
started blitzing them and I don't know I
don't don't know enough about football
but I remember on the Blitz and all of a
sudden the guy kid had to throw it away
or they sacked I might be like oh that's
interesting if they start doing this and
this is effective how does this [ __ ]
with Ohio State and it kind of shut him
down there for a minute and Clemson got
back into the game who watched the game
so we'll see what happens we shall see
what happens and um back in the day I
was complaining that Iowa State became
the number one team in the country
because they beat Penn State and
meanwhile LSU beat like [ __ ] four top
ten teams three top ten teams had a way
tougher schedule and I think my
complaining was right because there's
only two teams left and LSU was one of
them and Ohio State is not okay Columbus
I know you're hurting right now but I
just want you to know you never at any
point in this season ever deserved the
number one next to your [ __ ] name
my buddy law had actually was tweeting
how the [ __ ] is Clemson they won 29
games in a row or something how are they
not the favorite in this game you know
which I actually got a laugh out of that
cuz I know goddamn well
Buckeye fans [ __ ] all over Clemson as
far as like they play in the ACC there's
no competition yada yada ya that's what
makes college football fun all right
oh look at this we got a letter here we
got a letter this is from a lady this is
from a lady doo-dah doo-dah alright lady
defending bill burr hi Bill
parentheses insert clever name here oh
you tapped out anyway I have been
listening to your podcast for years ever
since I saw your special on Netflix not
sure which one it was it was the one
where I screamed and yelled and never
really made a point but it had but it
had how to block an incoming slap from a
woman and how normal men have never been
tempted at the level that famous men
have to deal with with extra curricular
activity yes anyway I just listened to
the mmm podcast from Monday before
Christmas 2019 and heard the lady flit
the letter from the lady that started
out praising and then turned nasty I
have to say that she is dead wrong you
might be misogynistic but you're not
wrong mostly on a lot of the things you
say you know something I would not I I
agree with that whole sentence a
misogynist thing I get I think towards
women as a group individually I root for
but when they all get together and they
start screaming and yelling it's just
it's kind of difficult to hear listen
this is my deal I just like [ __ ] with
people all right I don't give a [ __ ]
what women do I don't give a [ __ ] I hope
whatever the [ __ ] I do just hope you're
happy
I hope you're happy and then you go easy
on the guy in your life how about that
that's that's all I hope you know go be
president you want dead babies on your
conscience is that what the [ __ ] you
want anyway all right you might be
misogynist okay I've heard you tell many
men slash boys who wrote in for advice
to run from a crazy woman and do not
[ __ ] her because it's going to have
consequences
I actually think most of your advice
- men and women is pretty damn good
definitely oh wait a minute wait a
minute you know what that means if
you're talking advice you know we got a
play mic jingle where the [ __ ] is it did
I lose it
that was so anticlimactic where the [ __ ]
is it no producer yeah I haven't
producer was just nobody here when I do
this yes bill we know we've been
listening for a while Oh little ZZ Top
for you mo white guy and this is my
blues there I'm sorry all right where
the [ __ ] am i I have a lady defending me
I'm definitely a chick but I am able to
see some of my issues and it breaks my
heart how dumb a lot of young girls are
I was too though
ya know it was a stupid guy still AM a
stupid guy anyways and I for one
appreciate your honesty and your ability
to also look at yourself well thank you
this is actually a very nice letter
first out Seattle will it come back to
haunt them that they went for [ __ ] -
we shall see all right
I'm also sober and have been and have
been for a long time and I really do
miss it but I know I am totally
romanticizing what drink drinking would
be like if I attempted to control it now
not gonna happen you're not 100%
romanticizing it is fun it is fun being
a fat [ __ ] and being shit-faced when you
have a kid upstairs that's not fun but
that first one though oh that first one
is hearing that booze going over that
[ __ ] ice cube sorry good luck and be
happy with whatever way you you go with
that kisnya and cutie pie for me Oh a
nice look at that that was just like a
glowing sort of review you know little
that's how you do it ladies that right
there
bad men that's how you do it that you
you [ __ ] you know you be a gentleman
or a late
about it and I can actually hear what
you're saying
alright where the [ __ ] am i financial
advice for a young adult oh Jesus you're
asking me alright let's see what we got
here alright
okay financial advice for a young adult
hello Redbeard dr. Phil I've been
listening to the podcast since I've been
up been fifteen and just turned 24 Jesus
Christ you've been listening for nine
years
but enough of that I truly need some
help all right recently my father passed
sorry to hear that but and left me a lot
of money there you go
not a lot Jesus this is the ups and
downs of this first sentence but it's
about enough to live in New York without
a job for about seven years what the
[ __ ] you're talking about this that's a
ton of money
wait what part in New York what are we
talking here we talking like north of
Albany oh we talk in New York City
anyway it's not that I'm going to do
such a thing but it's just an example
not to make this a super long email I
just want some type of advice from
anyone older and more knowledgeable on
the matter I grew up without my dad so I
was never taught what you should do with
money oh so he wasn't in the picture huh
okay I've been waking up every other
morning with severe anxiety and stress
because of the fear that everything will
be gone and I won't be able to take care
of myself all right that's not gonna
happen neither one of those things is
gonna happen
most people go out in the world and they
don't have seven years worth of cash
that they could live off up so you're
way ahead of the game all right
even now thinking about it and writing
this to you gives me a sharp pain in my
gut full of fear yeah see this is the
thing this is the other side of you know
there's not having money there's that
stress and then there's a stress of
having it because yeah all right this is
an easy one here he goes I truly hope
you see this over the decade long time
I've been listening to your podcast this
is the one and only time I've tried to
email thank you either way for the last
even if you don't get this all right
okay but this very polite email you seem
like a really good person there are
plenty of places where you can learn
about money and you don't have to learn
it all by tomorrow so take a deep breath
exhale [ __ ] all of those fears and
you're gonna be the person who doesn't
blow the money you're gonna go out and
learn what to do with the money okay and
it's kind of hard for me to give you
advice on what to do with the money what
I would do is if I had enough money to
live for seven years I would maybe buy a
place if I could if I don't know how
much money that is or how you live but
if you could afford to buy a property
rental or a place where you're gonna
live you know in those seven years as
you build up your career you could have
a lot of equity built up in the house
buy something where you can be knocking
down the mortgage I mean I don't know I
don't want that what the [ __ ] do I know
but I do know that like I've ever seen
this thing on Duff McKagan Guns and
Roses right
yeah bass player when when the band hit
he would get these these spreadsheets or
whatever the [ __ ] they are they're
financial statements and like most
people he didn't know how to read them
and he actually went back to school I
believe in Seattle and got like a degree
in finance or something like that so I
mean there's a person that was playing
was a musician playing in a successful
band touring around the world and took
time off constructively to go do that
you know and he was able to do it and
understand money so if he can do it you
can do it you know you don't have a
world tour you know taking up all your
time you can just go figure this [ __ ]
out so I think you're doing the right
thing you know it's good that you're
nervous it's actually good that you're
nervous that you're gonna blow it we
need you respect this money that you've
been given so I don't think you can be
going out buying a bunch of shiny [ __ ]
and fur coats and dumb [ __ ] you know
there's just basic [ __ ] that can lead
you down the road you know how rich
people buy assets and poor people buy
liabilities like simple sort of you know
I mean that's you know there's a million
arguments within that but it's just as
far as like a building block or there's
[ __ ] pass interference right there
Jesus Christ
[ __ ] tackle the guy sorry um anyway
there's this a million ways to do this
all right but I what if I said we'll
give use do not put it in the stock
market that is the stupidest [ __ ]
thing you could ever do that is just a
completely rigged [ __ ] game and I
don't think it's really policed either
and they just rich people pump it up and
then they pull their money out right
before they know it's gonna [ __ ]
crash it crashes and then they buy a
bunch when everybody else is hurting and
then they build it back up again it's
just one [ __ ] bubble after another
yeah I would do that and then you know
don't go out and buy a grill you know
stupid [ __ ] like that so don't go out
and buy it a chain that has like a
pendant on it which is your face all in
diamonds I mean that's the type of Shi
that's how you go broke don't have you
know endangered species in your backyard
that you have to feed you know just live
within your means this is what I would
do over the next seven years I would you
know I I would learn how to invest the
money and I would continue to work and I
would live off the money that I make
from my job not from what's in the you
know or I would I would buy something
that with the job that I have I can make
the mortgage payment you know something
like that or you know I don't know
there's a million different ways to go
you can buy a rental property there's
all kinds of stuff that you can do with
it you know just don't go out and go you
know do the dumb [ __ ] your friends would
do Marshawn Lynch for a touchdown over
the top is that what just happened yeah
you go welcome back
all right okay
so good luck with that but you're you're
fine you're gonna be fine
don't listen negative voices like that
okay if you [ __ ] nervous about
something you open up to somebody and
then you try and find out where the help
is and then you go to it all right
online girl all right hey Billy I got an
audition I got a situation sorry that
I'd love your opinion on I'm a teen I've
met this girl online Oh is it really a
bearded Russian guy trying to get your
social security number who knows I met
this girl online we video chat and all
that so I know she's [ __ ] real lol we
are getting pretty close and I want to
visit but the thing is I'm not sure if
she is talking to someone else or is
just talking to me because she's bored
or no one is talking to her so she talks
to me for the [ __ ] of it maybe I'm being
paranoid idiot but it's I feel it's a
possibility I try not to keep hassling
about it but because I fear it will push
her away at the same time I keep my own
distant and try not to get too attached
so I don't get my heart rip to [ __ ]
shreds if she is talking to someone else
also I'm just starting my life and as an
adult I'm almost done with school and I
need to get a job I know I need to save
money from my adult stuff like a car and
rent etc but I really want to meet her
and make sure this is all legit
am I being an idiot by letting my dick
make the decisions well it sounds like
you're between your ears right now
thinking about all this [ __ ] I would
just say anytime you meet somebody that
you met online don't ever meet them at
their apartment or I wouldn't meet them
during the day in a public place with a
bunch of [ __ ] people especially women
meeting guys this is I don't need I
don't know anything about this don't
take my advice talk to somebody who
[ __ ] has done this anyway I just need
advice because the more I think about it
the more I start thinking about how
there might be another guy
I think I'm just a [ __ ] maniac but
any advice would be amazing much
appreciated and go [ __ ] yourself I don't
know dude
first of all there wasn't one period in
the whole last paragraph so I really
think your thoughts were getting away
from you you're flipping out all right
and here's the thing about this [ __ ] is
you know when you [ __ ] somebody's
from a distance you can really
romanticize them and everything's
[ __ ] perfect and you're not arguing
because they're really not in your life
so if you want to find out what this is
all about I'd like I said I would go
meet her in a very public place during
the [ __ ] day all right
you may or may not want to bring mace
you have no idea what's gonna happen
follow you you know I'd be a [ __ ]
paranoid as I am I'm like how do I know
this [ __ ] art he's talking to me
trying to get my dumb ass to come over
there and meet her and then I'm gonna
get jumped by your friends so I'd meet
her and one of those froze frozen yogurt
places nobody ever gets beat down of
those do they no Jesus no I gotta search
that let me see here frozen yogurt beat
down the life and death of a tart frozen
yogurt [ __ ] is that
best Froyo shops Froyo oh boy the life
and death of tart frozen yogurt never
forget red mango Pinkberry in 16 handles
I don't know what this is talking about
flavors right all right I thought some
kid got killed in a street name was tart
sorry about that okay 19 to 14 Seattle I
mean sorry 49ers Seattle's on their way
back I'm telling you I told you they're
gonna win the Superbowl you have to
listen to me because I played organized
football in third grade all right don't
love girlfriend anymore oh boy here we
go we
on this so we got an overrated
underrated coming up next door II don't
love my girlfriend anymore well I'm sad
to hear that all right dear Billy ginger
tits pretty soon it'll be dear Billy
lactating tits I'm 18 and in high school
I've known this girl since fourth grade
and we've been friends throughout our
school life a year ago I discovered that
I had feelings for her and told her
about it she did too
she was she's my first girlfriend
first-ever girlfriend for the first few
months it was amazing I couldn't get
enough for her I started thinking that I
loved her and maybe I still do but
lately it's been pretty plain welcome
sir welcome to being in a relationship I
still like her a lot but I don't feel
the spark anymore on the other hand I
know for sure that she loves me to death
and can't even imagine being away from
me she even talks about how we would get
married oh god these things are so tough
anyway when we first got together I was
also obsessed with her and talked about
our marriage and kids and all that all
right he goes but now it all seems so
stupid all right you got it you know
what you're [ __ ] young you don't know
what it is you know that young love is
crazy it's like it's like a [ __ ] baby
poisonous snake they even [ __ ] you
empty both thanks even though you don't
need to she's a lovely girl beautiful
human being she has never hurt me so I
don't want to hurt her by saying
anything that would do that I still show
the same interest in her like I did
before but I don't think it's genuine
anymore I asked her once one of things
were to go south and we were to break up
she started crying and she said she
cannot imagine living without me oh my
god oh god I'm so glad I'm married I
don't have to go through this [ __ ]
anymore I don't know what to do now I
can never gather the courage to break up
with her because I know how badly she
would be affected having said all those
things about our future it made all
those promises if I break up with her
she would think of me as a treacherous
person I don't want her to lose faith in
all men because that happened to another
friend of mine now give me a [ __ ]
break
you don't have all men on your shoulders
here
right you learning a tough lesson here
sir all right you really are you know
sometimes what you want is not what the
other person wants since somebody gets
hurt it just sucks it's it's like
anything it's like playing a [ __ ]
football game somebody's gonna win
somebody's gonna loose that's not a good
metaphor cuz sometimes you know I guess
I guess if you're a [ __ ] team yeah
you know what that was a bad metaphor
they just [ __ ] threw me off I thought
I had a point I don't think I do anyway
she has also said that if we were going
to if we were to separate that she would
go out and date any piece of [ __ ] with a
dick that's kind of weird
I've also I've known her for so long and
I really care about her and I don't want
anything bad to happen to her if we
break up I don't know why is she telling
you that I think she's I think she just
said that just so you wouldn't break up
with her help me bill how can I break up
with this lovely human being without
saddening her to the point of depression
and without becoming a bad person myself
any advice we greatly appreciated love
from India eat a bag of [ __ ] and go [ __ ]
yourself alright love from India you
know that's one of my favorite places I
ever went to [ __ ] people were cool as
[ __ ] and they were ball breakers to him
and really funny people let's see here
alright buddy well for all men and women
out there part of becoming adult an
adult is learning how to break up with
somebody and also part of being in an
adult is taking care of yourself in what
you want okay and not giving in to the
fact
oh this is gonna hurt somebody else now
I'm not talking about porn [ __ ] into the
drinking water because that's what you
want to do I'm just talking about in
relationships alright if you really want
to find love and you really want to you
know live this [ __ ] you know happy
life you have to be selfish and if
you're not into it anymore you got to
tell him and you got to tell him sooner
rather than later touchdown 49ers [ __ ]
I was feeling so right what is with the
choreographed the entire team
celebrations no loose white guy talking
[ __ ] to the camera you don't see that
much do they just give a sideline
reporter a helmet sorry uh let's see
here just sit her down say we got to
talk and just say this is the worst
thing I've ever had to do but the only
thing worse than this would be lying to
you which I don't want to do and just
say I am not feeling the same feelings
that I felt earlier and I need to be
single and figure out why that is jeez
that's pretty good man I mean what the
[ __ ] I mean it is that's it right there
and you know I wouldn't say please don't
judge all other men because of me
because and you come off like this
[ __ ] self-involved person just keep
it about yourself you don't have to drag
all other men down with you you just say
what it is that you're feeling and then
you say what it is that you want and
then she's gonna cry it's gonna suck but
it's gonna be over you know that's it
all right and then you know when you
break up then you need some time apart
okay cuz hell hath no fury like a woman
scorned and I'll tell you like I learned
very quickly that when you break up with
someone you get out of their life
because women they they do like they're
into vengeance and getting even and [ __ ]
like that and like when they get real
[ __ ] emotional like you know yeah the
[ __ ] you're gonna have a pet is gonna
end up in some stew as all I'm saying so
I always just like I don't want to know
what they're doing I don't want to know
they're dating I don't give a [ __ ]
and and who knows years later you come
back together you could have a cordial
[ __ ] conversation but I do know
immediately right after the whole
[ __ ] thing goes down that uh you know
it's usually good to kind of keep a
distance or whatever so whatever all
right so they go I don't need to get
into all of that [ __ ] you'll figure it
out you'll figure it out
again for the rest of your life whenever
you feel in that [ __ ] feeling you
know you have to address it sometimes
you just address it because is sometimes
it is because you're with the wrong
person and other times it's just the ups
and downs of the [ __ ] thing but I
don't know when you get to the point
where you just feel like you're being
phony yeah you do have to go address it
alright that's it enough on that alright
overrated underrated underrated spending
January in February by yourself no all
right I like that New Year's Eve just
you and some food and movies Super Bowl
just you beers food in the game
Valentine's Day just use some food and
whatever the hell you want I'll get to
so sure a lot socializing and March
that's all right the little serial
killer or maybe you're the next great
novelist spending time by yourself is
underrated
I am a I'm a recovered loner now that I
have a wife and a kid but I never had a
problem eat alone I don't know why but I
so I agree with that sir
alright I'll tell you what's overrated
overrated is [ __ ] picking the [ __ ]
Seattle Seahawks in November they're not
gonna [ __ ] beat the 49ers overrated
making a [ __ ] Super Bowl perfect
prediction in November come on Russell
make make me right laughs [ __ ] it's this
[ __ ] six minutes to go they're down
by I'm already down by that Jesus Christ
another 49 isn't gonna give up the
middle of the field to try to [ __ ]
burn the clock does this work
and
football fans anybody out there actually
coaches football does this work don't
get beat deep don't let him out of
Bounce so they just get [ __ ] one two
ten twelve yard pass after that Russell
Wilson goes back dumps it off a nice
pass rush to their alright anyways I
would not Richard Sherman feels coming
back to that building that's got to be
[ __ ] weird I know it's his second
season with the 49ers but uh what do you
guys think they're in Seattle did they
let him go too soon Kelly's is a major
injury but he's pretty much shutting
down that side of the field isn't he
he's still a young guy all right that's
the podcast everybody Happy New Year
everybody
and I hope you guys all have a wonderful
amazing successful next decade and
everything that you want comes true
don't be a [ __ ] go [ __ ] yourselves and I
will check in on you on New Year's Day
in a whole new decade oh Jesus